you already fat and now you're gay isn't
that enough can I check your levels sure
on a bad day I would rate myself as low
as 3 out of 10 I think every muscle foot
3 about a 3 out of 10 for sure hi how
are you Chris
[Music]
okay oh my god Maggie you have no
self-control you lose your mind in front
of food and you eat like a pig that's
why you're so fat and you can never be
skinny your stomach rolls are disgusting
and don't even think about wearing tank
tops with those fat arms spare everyone
the eyesore you repulse me and you get a
double chin when you smile so don't even
think about smiling
I've watched you fail crash diet after
crash diet you can lose weight but you
can't fix an ugly face go take more
photos of your body from all the angles
so you can feel more ashamed you are
disgusting and lazy and gluttonous and
an an unlovable fat piece of Chris why
here we are again on another fad diet
trying to be what others say you have to
be to be accepted why can't you just be
happy like you are you're fat get over
it do you think anyone will ever love
you do you think anyone would ever date
you or like you you're being used
because you're so nice and you want
everyone to be your friend because you
don't feel like they truly want to be
her friend you need to be like you're
already fat and now you're gay what else
can you do
get a grip on life you have to do better
you have to put yourself into so many
things and be great at them so people
don't understand and feedback we were
really not worth anything you don't
matter
[Music]
having now went through this exercise
together
what is your honest opinion of your
partner's attentiveness
the moment I first saw you I was like
wow like like you have such a striking
beautiful face I just feel like I know
your pain so well like I just so badly
wanna could you know tell you that you
are so enough and you're so worthy and
you just carry this like like incredible
energy like you I feel like I just feel
comfortable these things are like so
eternalized because I think you're
amazing I love your hair I love your
style you're so you're really cute I
don't know why you would think any
anything else it's crazy I feel like I
know you I'm just really glad I met you
do you mind if I give you
[Music]